nearly 70% of Brits are proud to call
themselves monarchists and one can't
help but wonder if this is partly due to
Megan Markel her effervescence is a
breath of fresh air into one of
Britain's most widget institutions the
marvel Sparkle has not only boosted
superficial things like sales of dresses
worn by the Duchess but her influence
has also inspired churches to welcome
new preachers after reverend curries
rousing royal wedding sermon and also
reminded us of the women of Grenfell and
our shared humanity however I think it's
a recent brilliantly bold feminist
speech in New Zealand that is perhaps
making the most waves she celebrated 125
years of female suffrage highlighting
that New Zealand was the first country
to grant women the vote a fact that I
and many others didn't know at a time
when President Trump has more or less
filed for divorce from the special
relationship the marriage of Megan Marco
and Prince Harry keeps at Union alive as
far as I'm concerned Megan is a marvel
and she's bringing the monarchy into the
21st century and I love it actually you
took it you know the irony of that
speech which was only about two and a
half minutes long she didn't say
anything the people said before but they
all did that speech was it if you ask
most people to quote something she said
they wouldn't be able to but they
wouldn't be able to tell you the dress
the price of the dress the designer
because that's what people are looking
at with Megan you're saying she's
changed things she's actually changed of
nothing the monarchy has accommodated
her that that's that's what's happened
there if they have a comedy they've
accommodate it but she didn't make it
happen the monarchy has modernized they
have accommodated her class she's the
first working class person ever to marry
into the royal family she's the first
bi-racial person to be in the royal
family and also they relaxed all the
rules for her like you know she was the
first person ever to be invited to
sundering them for Christmas as a fiance
a curtsy that wasn't afforded to Kate or
Diana
but you know she hasn't changed anything
and maybe she will change something at
some point but let's never forget it was
Diana who changed the monarchy big time
she just didn't blow the winds of change
she sent her she sent her and a tornado
saw it and she did it she did it with
stuff that matters Megan hasn't done any
of that yet didn't never forget Diana's
book no never forget Diana's work on
hiv/aids first person to ever hold the
hand of someone with it's cuz landmine
landmines eating disorders leprosy she
changed everything but she did it and it
cost her dearly now Megan I know she is
saying what she's saying about feminism
and yes it's yes she's saying it but you
have to you have to ask yourself whether
she should be saying it because the
Royal [ __ ] the whole point of the
monarchy is supposed to be neutral the
question is yeah what would you say if
say Prince Charles started to campaign
for against immigration uncultured
emigration what would you say well one
person is definitely not gonna be
campaigning against a it's a prince
Charlie never very welcoming say someone
did well and your point because for me
why I love Megan and what she's doing in
terms of female empowerment and actually
highlighting it what does she know that
she's even talking about it
we never see a royal touch on these by
the way I think you've gone a little bit
overboard I mean my goodness me this way
this lady of course I welcome the
arrival she can fix us to beat me or
blacks in there I've been the autumn
international make sure snows on
Christmas Day and negotiate breaks it's
not fair to say that let's see what the
Duchess of Cornwall said back in Camilla
parker-bowles us was in 2018 women of
the world truly is a global festival
dedicated to presenting work by women
and promoting equality for women and
girls and indeed no no she's president
of the women the Fall Festival you're
making out that this is the first one
you actually said
brilliantly bold feminist speech well
that's a brilliantly bold numbness tweet
from March this year on international I
said she is great but it's not like
there's no one else there well can I
just bring in because I totally did
commit I loved Camilla parker-bowles but
her a little tweak there's not comparing
comprised too much to Megan's wonderful
feminist speech and I'd like to show
another clip from her what she was
talking about in terms of actually
dealing with financial difficulties in
her life can we ever look
I am also fully aware of the challenges
of being able to afford this level of
schooling for many people around the
world
myself included it was through
scholarships financial aid programs and
work-study where my earnings from a job
on campus went directly towards my
tuition that I was able to attend
University and without question it was
worth every effort this is can I quickly
just say that I hand over to magic this
is someone who not only is in touch with
the issues of the 21st century in terms
of the women's movement and where we are
right now with it but also someone who's
in touch with real life struggles I
don't know any other month's closer to
you as someone who's that's a bit
heavier which I was but actually having
better having spent an evening dining
with her and talking with her in Canada
before anyone knew that she was dating
Prince Harry certainly before the
announcement the engagement I think
we're in danger of mixing two things up
and actually in both elements I want to
in a gentler way agree with June because
that was a bit falling right but
actually in a gentle ways the first
thing I'd say is the person as an
individual I think needs to be separated
from the symbol what she symbolizes for
the nation I agree it reflects a modern
Britain a monarchy that is comfortable
with modern Britain
I too am in a mixed Remagen woman as
well I too am in a mixed race
relationship with an American
increasingly people are marrying across
national borders and across ethnicities
and I think that that marriage
symbolizes that and the fact that this
country is comfortable with its that's
what what she symbolizes of course part
of what she symbolizes is all of the
class issues and the monarchy here
alerts a symbol that's just on saying
the symbol of the nation which is do she
did it because she individually I must
say having spent the evening talking to
her she's a wonderful Oh
and the only reason I didn't ask for a
number is I didn't think she had to
think I was chatting her up she knew who
she was at that time she was dating
Harry and he actually spent the evening
talking to me not but I do think she's a
very different person I mean Princess
Diana who is you say did a great do to
change the maliki but she didn't she
came from the traditional I'm not too
sure that you're right when you say that
the palace allowed or the policy I think
I think he made the decision not he's
headstrong enough yes and if you don't
like you I'm off to Bermuda it's not
Haley she hasn't actually achieved it
yes she can string a sentence together
she's a very smart girl she's a great
communicator I get all of that I get in
but I'm not sure how many more walls
there are t'l don't Donna knock down
most of the walls actually and and the
monarchy or hell no but no one's ever
talking about women's issues I'm talking
about a lot of the world they're about
she's about yes that is absolutely
talking about walls though they are
about to have a child soon and that
child will be mixed race and that's
gonna have a whole bunch of new
conversations gonna be had about you
know race relations diversity
Association which are at the moment you
can't deny heated debate but it will
help calm I think but I say you know yes
she's saying this stuff but the point is
should she be saying yes the monarchy
stadium into the 21st century and thank
goodness they follow the
the marriage over the years but that's
merely it for this week but before we go
there's just time for this we all know
footballers love a bit of attention and
and a parcel to an unusual goal
celebration but Venezuelan footballer
Eduardo Bello took things to another
level this week this is how he
celebrated after scoring in the first
minute for his side in the Chilean
Premier Division
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he shoots he scores more ways than one
that's Eduardo Bella you are our
straight shooter you do wonder season
without school one he should have got a
red card because he held up the game B
I'm sorry to be rather brew where did he
keep the ring what did he have that in
his person they would just run up the
stairs how many games has he been
carrying the daily so that you're being
a bit of a killjoy have to wait for
83-84 minutes left or a game or whatever
it is okay well 89 that's it for this
week's episode of the pledge thank you
for watching them we'll see you next
time
[Music]